thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez in less
than two weeks two sets of human remains
have been discovered at lake mead one of
them inside a barrel that washed ashore
now in that case police believe the man
was shot and killed sometime in the
1970s or 80s then on saturday two paddle
boarders came across what they thought
was a rock but turned out to be bones
police telling the 8 news now i-team
there are no signs of foul play and it's
not believed to be connected to the
barrel case so as things stand tonight
neither of these people in those cases
have been identified though police are
still working around the clock to try
and find some answers so what does that
process look like after someone is
missing for so many years madison
kimbrough spoke to a local dentist about
identifying human remains
dr kim of hollywood smile dentistry
shared with me some details he was able
to obtain just by observing these photos
you're about to see details that may not
be as obvious to the general public
you know it's definitely surreal
but
i think there's a larger part of me that
is kind of happy that this person was
found lindsay melvin recalls the moment
she discovered those human remains in
the sand at caulville bay saturday
afternoon but with the remains now in
the hands of the coroner's office
dentist dr min kim of hollywood smile
dental weighs in on how the teeth seen
here can help determine the person's
identity but based on the picture i saw
it seems like there is an extra teeth
you know not the crowns or veneers the
victim obviously had a lot of missing
teeth and there's a lot of music they
only have four teeth remaining in the
scar and those teeth were internally
stained you know that means uh there's a
little cracked line too when you look at
it dark black line in the picture that
means those are weird teeth he says in
order to verify whether the teeth are
real uv light testing needs to be done
and while it may be difficult to find
out the identity of these remains it is
possible based on the picture uh the
victim has a square jawline
and prominent um supraorbital which is
super orbital right here
supraorbital bony structure that means
the victim was a male
based on my opinion but we can learn a
dna um some sort of testing which is
known as a polymeric chain reaction we
can actually extract dna sample from the
teeth or bone structures pcr basically
amplifies millions copies of dna using a
small sample dna sample
so there is a large enough so the
scientists and experts can
analyze it and identify the victim
and while dna can be helpful in
identifying remains it will only lead to
a match if that person's dna has already
been collected by police or someone else
before they died in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now
the recent discoveries at lake mead have
drawn a lot more people to the area
hoping to find more mysteries and
because of that the national park
service is reminding everyone that you
cannot be out there for the sole purpose
of treasure hunting also drones metal
detectors and magnet fishing all illegal
anyone caught could face jail time or
serious fines